it's time for roses and roses you guys
the women told and what did Ari do I
know what you did okay everybody I'm
Lauren Zima thank you so much for being
here on roses and Rose day as you know
The Bachelor women tell all aired on
Sunday night at a special time and we
had a special moment Wow
we are gonna get in to it let's get the
roux it by the special moment I'm
talking about the Caroline thank you
guys you got that you saw the Caroline
thing we're gonna get to it okay so at
women tell all I love it because we see
all the ladies together for the first
time in a while
drink for the fashion Beca M statement
earrings Caroline saw see cut off
midriff situation with the very basic
instinct white pantsuit thing T is super
cute black lazy thing everybody looked
great it's great and drink for the
reactions drink every time Becca and
makes a weird face I love her faces
they're so cute and adorable so we drank
for the fashion for the reactions
now let's drink for the redactions
everybody how about those words that
crystal said that they cut out
we're gonna talk about that as well so
first of all glam shaming the glam
shaming nope nope nope I have no time to
discuss this moving on I was constantly
questioned about my readiness you're 29
you have a lot to learn still about
conflict resolution about I'm brought up
a lot of good points tonight you guys
you know once again she's criticized for
her age and once again why I don't know
about you but I'm feeling 22 year old
Becca she's really wise and she said hey
I was criticized for not being ready for
marriage yet Crystal's 29 and nobody's
pointing out that she really doesn't
seem ready for it a lot of things even
crystal talks about her flaws we're
gonna get yeah
so you know cheers to Becca for all of
her realizations and shameless blog
Becca emma is gonna be in our studios to
day you guys soup check it out you've
got another episode of The Bachelor
tonight so I've got a lot to talk about
Wow exhausted I mean two weeks six hours
the bachelor and bachelorette are games
combined two tell-all special who's
tired I'm tired I've had to go for some
heavier on the rose a you guys yeah so
crystal gets in the hot seat and man
these flashbacks to Crystal and Ari's
first dates are making me you realize
how different crystal seemed at that
time I felt so at home
how are you the older brother I look up
to for sure more grounded you know but
then we get the not so grounded crystal
and we see some never-before-seen
footage of crystal and who I learned
from crystal was Mikkel talking through
the the talking and careful crystal said
[Music]
[Music]
okay they bleeps that out so you guys
what she called re was a needle and what
she called the women well was a C C word
I loved how they stuck on baby on his
face the whole time and she was just
like you guys this taping was on another
level when they showed that this I was
like this is me grabbing a stranger you
know like again Becca drinking for her
so wise she says crystal just be you
just be the real crystal we would just
like you better if you were just you
don't try to curate a presence of like
just always then and love and peace if
that's not who you mean like just be
real about it who talks like that
god I wish we're all 22 no but I wish I
was that smart when I was 22 you get it
mmm I like I stumbled myself for sure
crystal does the things she's done all
season where she acknowledges some of
her flaws she admitted that she stumbled
and fell hard but then things turned
dark again and we're gonna drink for a
reaction we get moment number one of the
night from Caroline where seemingly
through tears in her eyes she calls
crystallis sociopath mm what a crystal
thing is that the interviews up now with
me TT I'm like calm this is gonna be a
lot of looks a lot of plugs but a lot of
good content from this you know so I
feel okay by plugging it I love you guys
gonna finish this glass real fast I was
pissed
I felt really that we were ejected and
crystals justification of a lot of her
actions was just that she was so mad and
she lost it and I want to discuss this
you guys and tell me what you think
crystals an adult and sure we do all get
mad and sure we do all go over the edge
I guess I don't know is that your Excuse
all the time as an adult don't you have
to take ownership of your actions you
see house
other people isn't that the problem here
but she did apologize stumbled and fell
I tried saying no that's not it try to
walk away a nice Tomball crystal okay
and you know what I want to drink every
time somebody had a good question like
crystal called re a needle and Viviana
said did you see it did you see it it's
good question the answer is no so Nate
dating a guy who's dating multiple other
woman whom I'm living with probably
isn't the best circumstance for me
finally crystal acknowledges what I have
I must pat myself on the back of up and
saying all the season she says that
maybe this show wasn't the best
circumstance for her it was not no
Crystal's got some stuff to work through
as we all do and this environment was
not the place for her to do that I just
had a question um so I'm hearing you
speaking now why did you speak like and
then drink again for a good question
from a woman who I don't know her
recognized I had no clue this person was
on the show but she asks why crystals
voice is different crystals explanation
is that cheap I've lost I lost my voice
for the time she was on the show so for
six weeks I think what it is is that
crystal just kind of got into a
caricature of herself and was just
living in that world it's the bachelor
bubble and that's scary what how do you
guys think you would do on this show let
me know in the comments I always wonder
this about myself like would I be able
to be Who I am or would I really go over
the edge over the edge Becca Becca again
drink for her wisdom she points out as I
have pointed out the Heather women on
the show for 23 24 25 Lauren being in
the top three it's 25 I don't get it and
to be honest I wasn't at the place where
you were at I was not at the place where
I was ready to marry him Becca seems
very her
by TIA by having seen what Tia said
about her on their final dates together
and you can check out whether she thinks
she and Tia will still be friends over
DT online.com it's a lot of good stuff
guys I wouldn't tell you that if it was
whoa giving you a heads up there's a
good chance she's going to be missing
for about two weeks this summer biggest
moment I thought from the Becca hot seat
was when she confirmed that she was on a
marijuana farm when she was missing she
kind of hinted at that she owned yes it
was a marijuana farm wonderful I love it
and as I told you guys the time line
didn't make sense there was no way she
was selling the show at that point am i
okay it's so much harder the past two
weeks everybody is everybody okay you
know if you guys are okay it's been a
lot I loved winter games Chris wants
back gonna come to paradise that moment
was a total surprise for her she told me
would she do it
maybe somebody can't win her country I
am a total nerd I do love like corny
jokes somebody well he stayed true to
that all season
here's here Tia in the hot seat and Tia
is frustrated that re couldn't really
give her an answer on why he sent her
home and I agree because we've been
confused all season and Chris says that
re told him he wasn't sure if he was
making a mistake in sending Tia home
that's gut wrenching oh got read Shana
so it allows me to see my words and what
I deserve in a relationship Tia says
she's vulnerable and says that of course
she's open to the chance of falling in
love again well God I would hope so too
you you're like 26 what do you guys
think should t be the Bachelorette will
she be the Bachelorette I asked her
about it somebody so re explains - Tia
that he was further along with Kendall
and I just don't understand that because
I thought his issue with Kendall was
that he didn't feel as far along with
her
tonight might be a refill night mmm ari
is addressing each of the women and he
tells Becca that maybe I think I let
that scare me off
yours I think arias feelings Rebecca are
pretty real if her age weren't a factor
would they be together and then we get
the moment so I mean the whole time
you've said that you are here because
you are trying to find a wife you guys I
have never seen someone make such a mark
for themselves during the women tell all
we kind of remembered Caroline I liked
Caroline but would you have remembered
her in the future if not for this oh my
god first she comes for Crystal then she
tells Ari I know what you did I know
what you did oh my god I can't you guys
even like being there in the moment and
watching that happen play out live was I
would say maybe even more intense than
it came across on TV I couldn't breathe
I couldn't breathe as far as I'm tired I
have been able to breathe for two weeks
waiting and waiting just for you guys to
see this I want to know what you thought
let me know what you thought what did
Ari do very different than what would
Jesus do turn water into wine I hope
anyway
um I would love to talk Ari on the couch
if that's okay
come on oh then crystal wants her moment
with Ari and did someone in the
background say no crystal said she
wanted to go to the couch
I think so oh my name's Zack I'm up here
because I felt like our goodbyes it's a
little cold to me I have to give Ari
props on this because his approach to
crystal was so different than an Ari
we've seen all season it was a different
side of him home in a way looking back
now I think I feel it was pretty
appropriate you know and again this
makes me wonder if Ari just wasn't
totally ready yet to be back on camera
when he became the bachelor and to that
end you guys I had an absolutely
scintillating interview with ABC
executive Robert Mills that is the BT
online calm right now and he addresses
the criticism that Ari has been boring
this season some people have said it so
he talks about it it's good
okay in the moment I was really upset
and really hurt I felt very rejected
oh and I love this because it drove me
crazy when Kristen would say things like
I have a target on my back on this
two-on-one I'm like don't you know how
the show works Ari said crystal says you
spent time with the other women and Ari
says yes
this is the bachelor yes cheers to you
Ari cheers to this side of Ari we got
the bloopers Chris Harrison loves those
bloopers he teases the crap out of those
bloopers and they were good again
another fun side of Ari I like to use
doing the squatting thing for Jenny
gotta get deep ari has the best Muppet
impression of almost anyone I've ever
seen as I've been saying these noises he
makes they're great and then we're in
the promo this season a slow burn and
you guys I think it's gonna be on fire
at the end fire flames
Chris Harrison says that he knows who
said it before
and Chris we also know that you have
said it before but that this is going to
be
[Music]
most dramatic and any this season what
did Ari do Caroline
by the way interview with Caroline is up
as well in her reaction after the whole
thing was also did everybody see Ari's
diss on Twitter into our website for the
animal situation Oh God so we get the
promo and did we see this boyfriend
coming again you guys I don't think I've
mentioned this all season I don't know
why I can't bring myself to care about
like who's boyfriend this is or what
he's doing
do you care I think it's because he says
I've got to get my girl I'm like whoever
that dude is hard pass I don't know if
he's Becca's or Lauren B's or Kendall's
ex but like no thanks and those flowers
those purple flowers they keep cutting
into and making it seem like you brought
those if you're coming back to try to
guess maybe marry you can upgrade I'm
saying yeah you the romantic overnight
dates flash fantasy suites whatever you
want to call them we change up the
terminology they air tonight and to I
was thinking about this have you guys
noticed that in the promo it says are
you the perfect match for our next
Bachelor Bachelorette how are you
supposed to know if you're perfect if
you don't know they're you know more
interesting than ever the season
considering the Becca and crystal and
many of the women have said they went on
Peter
again I address that in my interview
with ABC executive Robert Mills
oh my you know we didn't have the choice
Iman with this episode do you see what
did you think of all the crystal stuff
mmm I think about my time thank you
everyone so much for watching as usual
please leave me your thoughts in the
comments I love you guys so much I love
this show so much and I'm so excited to
see what Chris has promised me it would
be my last romantic ending and now after
two weeks of bachelor it's two episodes
two nights in a row
love you guys bye this is me grabbing a
stranger you know like oh no it's okay
don't put this in VC Ari I got it I got
it JC
I got it am i okay no I'm not